so I'm actually going to talk about
feather the file format so I guess real
quick preliminaries my name is Bill is
Stephen said I made a scientist at civis
analytics and I am NOT a feather
contributor I just think it's a really
cool project so i guess quickly before
we get started who here works with csv
files okay who has to share code with
other people or share data with other
people and who does this with CSV files
what about parque or Avro or anything
from the Apache foundation okay so few
people so real quick feather is just a
file format put together by West
McKinney and headley Wickham based
loosely on arrow with the explicit
intent of having a cross essentially a
cross-platform cross-language way of
exchanging data that maintains maintains
type information metadata and stuff like
that so CSV s are obviously not typed
they're just they're just text so you
lose a lot of information a lot of
information that kind of matters through
a lot of stuff that we do so there are
no date time types there are no category
called types you essentially get strings
and numbers and it's up to every every
CSV parser implementation to sort of
decide how to interpret those things so
one of the ways that feather improves on
this is again it records the type
information when the file is written so
this makes it much easier and much
faster to to parse the file and
reconstruct the intended representation
in whatever language or whatever tool
you're sharing the data with so as Wes
McKinney says on the original blog post
it's it's really about the metadata the
metadata maintaining the data about the
data so I guess we talked about CSV
files and not to not to hit on pandas
too much but this is just a sign of how
tough it is to par CSV files I think
there's probably about 50 different
options here you know I I think when i
first started dealing with data and
python I used to just do you know for
I infile split on comma that worked when
I was writing the CSV file but it
definitely did not work when other
people gave me the CSV file so i think
as anybody knows mac and windows have
different ideas about how lines should
end and it's a lot of a lot of trouble
and reading and writing data should be
the most boring and simple thing in your
workflow you just want to get it into
your tool of choice and start doing work
and that is one of the reasons that read
CSV and pandas has so many options and
so many default values you just want to
point it at a file and get different
back and nothing else you don't want to
figure out like you know do I need to
deal with different in coatings is this
utf-8 is it s key is this some sort of
compressed file are the lines lines have
a carriage return or they have a newline
character so they did do a very good job
of just making this work ninety-five
percent of the time you get a data frame
back which is great but we could be
better so I guess I guess a long
digression to understand a little bit
about why feather and arrow and parquet
and all of these not csv file formats
are a little bit better we need to step
back and talk about computers so it all
starts with sand and somehow we get from
there to computers but we'll we'll skip
a few steps we you know in writing
software we spend a lot of time trying
to abstract things away so we like to
think that memory and a computer is just
one big hash table and we could read any
value arbitrarily that probably was true
like 20 or 30 years ago it is definitely
not anymore because we've had decades of
growth at different rates in the speed
of CPUs versus the speed of main memory
and disk access so memory speeds have
have grown at a rate much much slower
than CPUs so I like so yeah we think
it's a big hash table in access memory
anytime you want wherever you want all
constant time in reality we have this
really complicated hierarchy of caches
and buses and some are shared between
cores some are shared across
course some are unique to a single core
so really keeping the the CPU occupied
doing your data analysis doesn't really
require understanding these at a
fundamental level but it requires
knowing that there is something there
where that it is not as simple as as the
previous slide implied so this is my my
colleagues call this Bill's greatest
hits I post this on our hip chat room
all the time this is really from Jeff
Deane entitled numbers every engineer
should know these are relative latency
numbers going from reading something
from l1 cache all the way through
sending a packet across the world and
back so really we want to be in the good
place at the very top we want to be
reading stuff out of the cash we don't
want to have cache misses and things
like that so the way this really works
is when you go to fetch a value from
main memory rather than grabbing just
that value the the CPU grabs an entire
cache line and I think on modern Intel
CPUs that's something like 64 kilobytes
or 60 some big number i'm not entirely
sure what it is but when you so for
example if you wanted like this yellow
my Master's show three you wanted this
yellow value it's going to load the
whole thing in and if you next want the
blue value well hey great blue value is
already in the cache so you don't have
to go back through main memory and the
CPU sits idle while that's happening so
what does you know what's the
implication of this for like data
analysis and reading and parsing data so
it really means that the data layout on
memory and on disk needs to be tailored
for how you were actually going to
access at night I'm sure this is
probably obvious to everybody here
that's why there's also the Fortran
people and the sea people have a
completely different idea about how
matrices and arrays are laid out of
memory so to really take keep your CPU
occupied while you're doing data
analysis memory needs to be you know
memory access depends on locality and
predictability so it's really about
sequential access reading things in
order from left to right or right to
left or whatever just making sure that
it's predictable and ordered will ensure
that you'll have
good time and keep the CPU occupied so
that brings us to feather which is again
loosely based on the arrow file format
and the idea here is that obviously the
Don disk representation of tabular data
should look just like the thing that's
going to be in memory when it's all red
so we really want zero parsing we want
to just move the data from disk to
memory without doing any extra work of
translation and the other insight that I
think the redshift is based on this
parquet a lot of more modern analytics
tools are based on the idea that our
workflows I generally based on columns
so think about taking the mean of some
value and as sequel database looks like
that we generally do stuff on columns
rather than on on Rose so organizing in
that case the Fortran layout organizing
the data in memory by my column makes
more sense in organizing it by row so
what that looks like is is this so this
is actually from the arrow website at
the top is is the data as you would
think of it it's a table in this
particular example it's session ID
timestamp in that source IP so imagine
like some access logs or counter
something like that so on the on the
left hand side here this is ordered by
row instead of ordered by column the
right hand side is worried by com so all
the values for the session ID our first
followed by all the values for timestamp
followed by all the values for source IP
so imagine you're trying to answer the
question you know like a distinct count
on source IPS on the left hand side
you're you're randomly skipping over
fields to reach of the the red rose on
the right hand side you just find the
offset of the start and you read all the
way through to the end so it's
sequential access CPU is reading from
the cache most of the time instead of
consistently or constantly invalidating
the Cashin and swapping from memory so
again this brings us to simplicity we
don't have to do any park scene because
the feather file format maintains the
types so reading is about the most
uninteresting thing possible there are
no
shins other than overriding column names
you just give it a path and you get a
pandas dataframe back so the exact
opposite of pandas I think pandas have
sensible defaults it's very rare that
people actually have to mess with these
but there are there so this is what the
actual the actual representation looks
like on disk it starts with a magic
number and ends with a magic number and
then each column is serialized as an
array with some more metadata there's a
bitmask at the very top that maintains
the list of na s so dealing with float
values there is a special and a type but
there is no na tech for Strings there's
no real obvious na type for integers and
other other data types so they kind of
sites up that problem and just
essentially maintain a list a bit mask
of the things that are not on the things
that are not followed by the actual
values themselves so if if these are
just simple types with fixed size it
will be the representation on the top so
think like an array of floating point
values if it's a variable size array so
like an array of strings it will be the
bottom one again null bit mask and then
value offsets recording where the start
is of each value in the array so this is
I guess I didn't draw that you know
imagine this is turn 90 degrees looks
roughly like data frames in our the the
pandas one is a little more complicated
but the idea is still pretty much the
same the actual data structure is a list
of columns and each column is 2.2 to an
array of the actual values so we'll do
some live code and we'll see what
feather actually looks like and
so everybody look away for a second I'm
going to do something in our so we just
loaded the the iris data set I'm sorry I
don't have anything more interesting but
this is available everywhere and
everybody should have it memorized by
now so we're just going to write this to
a feather file let's we will call it
iris from our sorry I can't spell today
either and we'll quickly quit out of our
so hopefully nobody saw that and we'll
go back to python so if we can skip the
stuff at the top for now loading that
data into python is essentially just
import the the feather package and then
we read it with read feather and now we
have a nice pandas dataframe that's the
oh sure how's that it's pretty good
sorry oh thanks so that hopefully looks
exactly like the our representation so
we have some I don't have no idea what
these things actually represent some
sort of flour and then the species
column so all the stuff that's supposed
to be there is hopefully there notice we
didn't specify any options to read data
frame it just turned out the way it was
or turned out the way it should be so
now I guess will will will read this in
hard mode will actually deconstruct and
and read it manually so as I mentioned
earlier that the feather file format
stores metadata about the columns at the
very end of the file and they do this
using flatbuffers are there any Google
people here okay so flatbuffers is a is
a google project python support is not
actually all that great you it works
sort of like protocol buffers and those
similar tools and that you write a
specification
that kind of looks like see Strix this
is what it looks like and then it will
generate code for you to read and write
the metadata so I think this was just an
arbitrary choice by the the feather
authors JSON probably would have
accomplished the same thing but in this
case they they get some sort of typed
representation of the metadata so behind
the scenes I generated the feather the
metadata the flatbuffers bindings for
the feather metadata and here we're just
reading it in so we're just going to
load that entire feather file into just
a byte array and in Python so that's
just what we did at the top we're going
to unpack the metadata so very end of
the file they store the metadata size so
we're just going to look up that and
that'll tell us how far to back up from
the beginning of the file to the start
of the metadata and then we'll read the
metadata here using this crazy weird
command that I had to actually look up
it's not the most well-documented thing
and then we'll just print out the
columns that are in the feather file so
we can see sepal length sea bowl with
petal length pedal with and species and
then these are the offsets where each of
the values actually start so we can take
a quick peek at that so let's this one
is 1208 so to remember that so this is
just a hex dump of the the feather file
that I just wrote I we said that column
was 1208 sent right yeah so right here
we have the 3.5 and that should be 3.5
okay so yeah this is what it looks like
on I'm not actually on disk again we
start with the the magic number and with
the magic magic number
we have the the metadata size here and
then actual metadata here and then a
bunch of columns in between and then
back to Python so I guess just for fun
we can read one of these files into an
umpire or one of these arrays into an
actual numpy ray so we'll do the easy
one which is just a string I'm sorry
just a floating point value or an array
of floating-point values so we grab the
column metadata find the the location
data and then just read from the file
from that offset plus the total bytes
and we end up with a numpy ray so this
should be the sepal length which is this
one so 5.1 4.9 so it looks about right
hopefully and then some of the harder
ones reading the string string column
names is a little bit trickier these are
encoded these are done in two places the
list of the categories of the list of
the strings is maintained somewhere else
and then what's stored in the actual
array of values are just integers
pointing to the the label array so this
one is actually a lot trickier to ours
since the values themselves are integers
and the actual string values are stored
elsewhere pulling apart the pieces is
not super obvious so we can oops can
actually take a peek so these are the
species which are there are three of
them I believe and they're just numbered
zero through two and then if we really
wanted to we could convert those two
strings by looking up the value array at
the end of the file so they record it
they just concatenate them all together
so this is all of them squeezed together
without spaces and then we could convert
that to an umpire ray and stitch them
together and recover the the actual
categorical representation so that's it
for the live code
and so what what are some other
potential uses for feather so to date
they've only finished like reading and
writing and they're really in like the
proof of concept stage beyond that so
these are like some things I personally
like to see oh sorry it should be full
screen in place operations so a lot of
the things you do on pandas arrays it
would be pretty great if you could just
memory map the feather file and be done
no parsing no moving no copying you want
to do some sort of select based on rows
or columns it would be pretty great if
you just didn't have to actually read
the file the the feather file it just
happened what happens right now is since
Python and all have very different ideas
about exactly how data frames are
represented the data are actually copied
from the feather format into the the
native representation of a data frame an
R or a data frame and Python the other I
guess another nice thing about being
able to share or in place operations is
that you would be able to share some of
the operational code between languages
so instead of having pandas and having
are you would have a c++ library or c
library that just knew how to do all of
the common data frame operations and
semantically it would be equivalent in
the two languages so that would just it
would make it much easier to collaborate
and I just covered zero parsing copying
and also as like a defacto interchange
format so as input to tools I
scikit-learn your stats models which
already do a pretty good job of dealing
with pandas data frames scikit-learn in
the background just kind of converts
them to numpy rays and i'm pretty sure
it's the same with decimals I don't see
skipper in here to disagree with me but
I'm I assume that's the case it would be
it would be great if we could pass and
you know our does a very good job of
dealing with things like categorical
features and things like that so I could
learn that's to some extent up to you
the user to to do that expansion but it
would be pretty nice if we could
pass an entire data frame to second
learning with the types the types
included and just get that have that
done automatically forest like some
parts of our do and then also as as
output from tools like postgres so I
think the the spark and the spark and
had new people are doing this with
things like arrow and parquet in that
the the data storage tools are
outputting these formats that are
recognized and usable across different
languages so there is little parsing
when you're moving from where the data
are storage where the data are used and
then through your your analysis pipeline
so that's mostly it I'll turn it over to
questions and I guess I would also like
to reverse a little bit and hear from
you folks what keeps you using CSV files
and what would make you switch to
something like feather and not CSV files
oh yeah with that questions and comments
yeah that is actually stored in the
metadata the only and the only encoding
they have right now for string values is
just utf-8 there's no nothing else it's
just utf-8 that's a good question
actually don't know I would imagine they
would probably just stick to the the one
data format to rule them all but
certainly not out of the realm of
possibility I think they do have an
option just to store raw bytes so that
would certainly be an option to sidestep
like a particular format that's not
supported sure
there is not oh sorry is there any
support for concatenate and feather
files correct no not yet I think that
would probably require a deuce amount of
work just because of the way the
metadata are constructed and the way the
the file is structured I think you would
have to rewrite the entire file to
concatenate two files so it's probably
not like an in place or a simple
operation they would definitely require
like some processing and copying of all
the data and it's not quite as efficient
as just concatenate into csv files
unfortunately sure so the question is
how does it handle escapable characters
and things that it should be included in
the cell so it it's not like a delimited
format so it's not putting commas in
between string values it's the all
booked the column types are tight so it
knows that this thing is a array of an
array of floating point values this
other thing is an array of strings and
it stores the for the string since they
don't have a fixed length it stores the
start of each string in the array so if
it has a what would normally be a
delimiter like a comma or something like
that in the middle of the string it just
it doesn't matter it's just part of the
string value that it happened to save
hey hey else sure so how different is
the feather format from the in-memory
repins representation of pandas and are
it's pretty similar to our minus the
metadata part our is essentially just a
list of pointers or an array of pointers
to a raise of floating point numbers or
integers or strings the pandas one is a
little more complicated because they
have a block manager that jams columns
together of the same type I think
there's been some discussion about
changing this lately
but it's actually closer to our than it
is to pandas so I'm sure that's
something that really eventually
converge on and maybe with pandas 2
point 0 or pandas one point out I guess
anything else sure so the question is
does it support sparse data frames not
yet to my knowledge I think that's still
very much a work in progress I'm sorry
yo yeah it's definitely on the radar
there there's been a few issues that
people have filed about supporting
sparse data frames yeah
so
actually that is a very good point and
they do actually have big oh sorry the
comment was csv files are a great
long-term archival format because they
require little knowledge and you don't
rely on tools being available to read
them because they're just plain texts
that fair characterization and I
absolutely agree with that and they
actually have big bold letters on the
github repository saying not to use this
as an archival format again because you
can't just call less on it and see
what's going on that's definitely a
drawback but I think at least in my work
I tend to spend a lot of time taking
data from like a CSV file or from some
database and turning it into a CSV file
and then doing something with it in our
returning another CSV file and then
doing something with that in Python and
and a CSV becomes our way of exchanging
data between steps in a long data
processing pipeline and I think that's
where feather-like could really shine
anything else great thanks